billionaire businessman dan gilbert is
speaking only on cbs this morning
about tackling some huge challenges
gilbert who owns the cleveland cavaliers
founded rocket companies the parent of
the mortgage giant quicken loans
in 2010 gilbert moved his business
headquarters from the detroit suburbs
to downtown his companies have since
acquired and developed
more than 100 properties to help
transform
the motor city today he's announcing a
500 million dollar initiative
to revitalize neighborhoods in his
hometown cbs this morning saturday
co-host dana jacobson
sat down with gilbert and his wife in
their detroit area home
nearly two years after he suddenly
became ill
dana good morning good morning anthony
dan gilbert has
always been a determined self-starter as
a kid he bought
candy wholesale and sold it to his
friends for a profit
as a teenager he made chef boyardee
pizzas in his mom's kitchen
and started a delivery service until the
health department
shut him down but when this
hard-charging entrepreneur had a stroke
nearly two years ago
everything changed in an instant i'm
feeling good i'm getting better it's
like an inch a day you know it's a
marathon this thing coming back from it
dan gilbert welcome to detroit everybody
the charismatic billionaire who built a
mortgage
lending empire
and owns the nba's cleveland cavaliers
is still recovering from the stroke he
suffered
in may 2019. it was long enough already
to have a baby it's been nine months
a journey that's taught him the
importance of gratitude
in that moment where you realize this is
all changed what is that like for
someone like you
it's very scary for anybody and you
start to appreciate everything and
everybody much more than you ever did
humbling yeah it's definitely humbling
you said that just
everything is hard when you have a
stroke right that's the problem with it
half your body is gone in my case the
left half
luckily i'm a righty gilbert remembers
his near-death experience
vividly that night there happened to be
a light show on the river
all of a sudden i started seeing double
vision i thought it was because of the
lights
and luckily one of our good friends who
was there having to be an er doctor
i mean how about that for luck huh
incredible he made sure we
and my wife as well made sure we went to
the hospital right away his wife
jennifer has been by his side throughout
his recovery
yeah when you have a stroke it's like
the whole family had the stroke it
changes the whole dynamic it does but i
will say that
you know in a crisis our family rallied
has
the battle to come back been tougher
mentally or physically
i think it's been tougher mentally it
plays with you because you always ask
yourself every day
is this ever going to be over or not and
you hope it will be
but even in the midst of his challenges
gilbert remains committed to his
decade-long mission
to help revitalize detroit we need to
gain momentum
we need to have a lot of companies that
want to be there because it's smart for
them to be there i like to see the
people of detroit
benefit i mean look at the energy level
downtown right now we've got to carry
that through to the neighborhoods and
have the whole city have that
energy so gilbert and rocket companies
ceo jay farner are announcing a new
initiative
to invest 500 million dollars into
detroit's
neighborhoods over the next 10 years
using the first 15 million
to relieve property tax debt for
homeowners it was very clear to us that
it was
property taxes that caused the majority
of the blood in detroit
and vast majority of citizens at one
point were in tax foreclosure
with interest and penalties that debt
kept building in some cases
more than they owed on the mortgage and
people would just walk from the houses
because
they just couldn't afford it anymore
that money will cover everyone
in the city that's delinquent it'll
cover about 20 000 homes
probably 40 000 or more family members
the idea here was how do we really a
stabilize
the families in detroit and then be
start creating wealth and the first
thing you need to do is make sure that
people have a place to live
to make sure they understand what the
community wants
jennifer gilbert participated in
listening sessions in detroit's
neighborhoods
which are about 80 percent
african-american probably the worst
thing we could have done
is had everything figured out
and written a check so we did a lot of
listening
there are people that look at it
sometimes that it's
here are these people from the suburbs
white people coming
in to change a black community or
save the black community and we don't
need saving are you sensitive to that
how does that even make you feel when
that is raised
well the more you listen the more you
learn and the more you realize you have
to learn
as long as we continue with that
philosophy
and we stay close to it and we stay
close to
the people and the communities we can't
help but have a positive impact we're
empowering
the people from within the communities
to
come up with the solutions whether it's
rebuilding detroit
or recovering from a stroke gilbert says
he's learned a big lesson
america loves a comeback story right you
already knew that with the cavs come on
yeah there you go has there been a
lesson learned here
that you would pass on to other people
you know i would say it's just
the old cliche of the only thing that
matters is your health and your loved
ones
you can't control bad things from
happening but you control
how you respond to them and
so for us it really is is just being
mindful
of how can we make the best of this
situation
and how can we find moments of joy
gilbert says that the stroke also taught
him that he doesn't have to be the one
to do everything learning to rely on
family at home and his team at work
at the time when we spoke a few weeks
ago he was going into the office twice a
week still using a wheelchair and said
he was doing physical therapy
three to four hours almost every day to
regain
strength and movement tony two things
that need no rebuilding his fighting
spirit
and his sense of humor yeah yeah he came
across
dana that was a beautiful piece thank
you very much you can also tell how
how hard a battle is for someone as much
of a as a go-getter as he is
yeah that's a big wall to climb i just
think that some cliches are cliches
because they're powerful and true and
the importance of gratitude how family
takes center stage when your health
falls away all these things are just
fundamentally right and true and
we need reminding but to go through all
that i have to confess i didn't know
that it even happened to him
so it's so good to see that he's going
to be okay seems to be okay
but even in the middle of all this that
he's still trying to figure out how he
can help other people that's
extraordinary and
jennifer gilbert i thought what she said
was so important that she decided to
listen
yes because sometimes you think if you
have a lot of money i can show you
what's best for you
i can go in and fix this i can fix it
but to listen to what the what the
people want and how it benefits them
that's always it's so smart to do but
it's it's great
a lot about them as a couple great what
they're doing for detroit exactly
thousands of people could benefit